so uh if everyone is ready then we'll
continue um with chumming uh sue from
duke he'll tell us about uh
planted matchings perhaps um okay
yeah thanks for the introduction um and
thanks for coming to my talk
today i would like to talk about one of
my recent work on testing network
correlation
so this is a joint work with hong oo and
yale and then
sophie at duke i think they are all
online so they might
help me to answer the questions that you
have during my talk
um so let me get started by first
recalling the graph isomorphism problem
so given two graphs a and b graph small
reason is to decide
whether a is isomorphic to b or in other
words
whether there exists a bijection pi
between the two vertex sets
such that every edge in a is mapped to
every edge in b
so here is a classical example
illustrating the difficulty of graph
isomorphism
so in this process even though the two
graphs appear to be rather different
but they are in fact are isomorphic to
each other
so the underlying isomorphism is given
as follows and also highlighted
using the same colors in the plots
in the worst case the graph isomorphism
is actually not known to be solvable in
polynomial time
and you can imagine in practice we can
encounter a more difficult scenario
that two graphs may not be exactly
isomorphic
but we're still interested in telling
whether they're like their topologies
are similar
um so fortunately real networks are
arguably not necessarily in the worst
case
so this consideration motivates us to
move beyond worst case
and can see the graph as a small vision
in the average case
so in particular we consider this noisy
graph
as a morphism problem as a hypothesis
testing problem
so we observe so suppose we observe two
random graphs a and b
um under the null hypothesis h0 a and b
are independently generated and on the
h1
suppose there's a latent node
correspondence given by this uniform
permutation pi
and then under this latent node
correspondence
a and then permitted version of b pi
actually are edge correlated
in the sense that a i j and b pi pi j
are correlated random variables
now the goal is to distinguish these two
hypotheses
based on observation of this single
realization of these two random graphs a
and b
so note that under this alternate
hypothesis
this inherent edge correlation is
actually obscured by this latent
node correspondence pi which makes this
problem challenging
and also as a result the test that you
develop
needs to rely on so-called graph
invariance
the graph properties that are invariant
on the graph as a more visible
for example like the subgraph counts
like the number of triangles
or edges or like the spectrum like the
eigenvalues of adjusted matrices or
laplacians
um in our work we actually consider two
special settings of this general
setup one is the gaussian setting the
other is this other shiny setting
so for the sake of time in this talk
we're going to focus
exclusively on this other chinese
setting
so this setting was first proposed and
studied by the previous work barack at
all in particular under null hypothesis
the two graphs a and b are just
independent of the shiny random graphs
with n vertices and then edge
probability p times
s on the alternate hypothesis
again there is underlying latent
permutation pi
and under this latent permutation a and
the b pi
actually are independently h subsampled
from a common
parent graph that is order changi g n
comma p
with sub sampling probability s so in
other words
here we assume that there's a common
parent graph that is audacion e
and then every edge in this parent graph
will be included
in a with independent independency with
probability
s and that we kind of repeat this edge
sampling process to obtain the second
graph b pi and as you can see since both
graphs are subsampled from this common
parent graph
so they are correlated in edges
but note that if you check under both
edges 0 and h1
marginally those two graphs actually
order chain e with n vertices at 4bps
um but under h1 then with the
correct node correspondence the pair aij
and b pi
pi j are correlated with nuni random
variable
with correlation actually given by this
formula here
so roughly speaking when p is small the
correlation
is roughly given by this h sub sampling
probability
s okay so if s is higher that means this
correlation is higher so these two
distribution will become more distinct
i should also mention that the problem
here is actually i have post testing
aspect of this
graph matching problem where for the
graph matching problem the goal
is actually to recover this underlying
permutation
under the alternate hypothesis so this
talk we consider this hypothetical
version and we want to understand
when we can distinguish these two
hypotheses
um so let me now now first present our
main result
so first we derive a sharp threshold for
detection
in the dense region um so recall that
n is the number of nodes p is that
probability and s
is the subsampling probability s
so we show that if s square is bigger
than this expression here
then the total variation distance
actually converging to one as n goes to
infinity
um conversely in the density gene when
the edge probability p
scales as n to the power of minus little
one
then we almost get a matching like
negative result
so when s square is less than or equal
than two minus epsilon
times log n divided by this expression
where epsilon is any arbitrary small
constant positive constant
then the total variation distance
actually converging to zero
so pictorially you can visualize the
results
using this following phase diagram so
here
the x-axis is the kind of you can view
as a rescaled
uh correlation that is given by this mps
square
times log over p minus one plus p
divided by log n
so under these rescaling then basically
if you look at
the asymmetrical value of total value
distance this actually jumps from zero
uh to one at the sharp threshold two
okay so below the threshold even the
weak detection is impossible
in the sense that it is impossible even
to strictly
outperform just randomly guessing the
hypothesis
and above the threshold we can show that
strong detection is possible in the
sense that
you can correctly distinguish these two
hypotheses with a vanishing error
probability
so jamming just just to check this is
corresponding to the case where
the sort of intersection graph has
average degree log n
um it's actually more than um
average degree log n so
so the average degree under the
intersection graph is actually
mps square so if you view
that is mps square big or equal than log
m divided by log one over p
so this is actually a dream where the
average degree elimination graph
actually converging to infinity okay
sorry can you say what you
can you say what you mean by the
intersection graph here oh right yes
so the intersection graph basically you
have two graphs and then the
intersection graph just means the graph
actually includes all the common edges
in the two graphs
so you have aij and you have b i j so
the intersection
of a intersection b is just all the
edges included
in both a and b so since you want the
edge for
x to be subsampled twice so that's why
you have s squared
so that's why the edge probability is
like p times s square
so the average degree is n times p s
squared
so the condition here requires that like
you need
mps square to go to infinity to be able
to
achieve a strong like the total range
distance actually goes to one
okay okay
so sorry so can i does this mean that if
i
if i did exhaustive search over all
permutations of the vertices
so that i found i would found a b which
has a high a large intersection with a
yes so i'm actually going to talk about
later like how we get this possible
result and that's exactly
as you suggest we're looking over all
the possible permutation
and then compute the maximum correlation
between the two graphs
okay so we also obtain similar results
for the sparse regimes but the picture
here
is slightly less clear so we still have
the possible results that i stated
earlier
but for the negative results in the
sparse region we're focused on p
like scales as n to the power of minus
constant
then we're able to show that if s square
is less than roughly one or minimum of
one over np
and then 0.01 then the total variation
distance
is actually bounded away from one and
furthermore if s squared is less than
the minimum of one over n p
and then a little of one then the total
variation distance is actually
converging to zero
okay so roughly speaking the negative
results here
combined with possible results allow us
to identify the threshold within a
constant
so let me mention a special case to
illustrate the result
so if we look at the constant average
degree case where p
is equal to some constant d over n then
these results imply that the strong
detection is possible if s squared is
bigger than this constant two over d
but it's impossible if s squared is less
than one over d and the minimum of 0.01
okay um
okay so after identifying the
statistical detection limits a next
level question
is can we achieve this limit efficiently
and so a simple kind of testing
statistic to consider is actually just
based on counting the degree
on the edges in the two graphs and then
if the number of edges into graph is
very small then you declare that is in
the alternate hypothesis
and this turns out to achieve weak
detection in linear time
when the s is above a constant
now the previous work by barack at all
actually consider more sophisticated
subgraph counting so they in particular
they consider counting
so-called balanced sub-graphs of
constant size
and they're able to correctly
distinguish the two hypotheses
with the character probability at least
0.9 in polynomial time
if again s is above a constant and then
the average degree fall into this
particular range
so this condition here is because they
because of their special construction of
the balance the subgraphs
more recently like in a companion work
we actually obtained some new results in
the sponsor regime
based on counting certain weighted trees
of growing sizes and this is actually
inspired by the low degree polynomial
approximation
of likelihood ratio so in particular
we're able to show that by counting the
weighted
trees we can achieve strong detection
polynomial time
when again s square is bigger than this
constant and
also when the average degree is actually
in this range
um so this particular this constant
actually comes from the number of
unlabeled trees
of a given sizes um so this result
is an odd optimal in the sparse region
when you have an average degree
so the positive result here
comparing to the negative result differs
by a constant factor
so even despite these latest
developments i think a big open question
in this problem
is that whether there exists polynomial
time test
for someone linear s and this question
is still widely open
um in the remaining time i would like to
actually talk about how we prove these
results briefly
and also try to highlight some of the
new kind of proof
ideas so the
proof of possible result is actually
relatively simple
so we consider this particular test
statistic
that is computing the maximum edge
correlation
uh by maximizing all the possible latent
node correspondence
and this optimization problem is known
as quadratic assignment problem
and it's empty heart in the worst case
so that's why this test statistic is not
computationally efficient in the worst
case
as desired this statistic is invariant
to the node re-laboring
okay so if you relabel the nodes in a
and b the test statistic the value won't
change
and the proof of the success of this
statistic is relatively simple
just based on the same first moment
calculation or like
using a union bound
but i want to mention that the proof of
negative results is much more
interesting
and then also much more challenging so i
would like to focus on in this talk
so in particular applies this so-called
second moment method
so it is well known that if we can show
the second moment
of the likelihood ratio is big over one
then the total variation distance is
actually bounded away from one
okay in this case the strong detection
is impossible
if further if you can show the second
moment of like ratio is one plus little
one then this implies the totalization
distance actually converging to zero
so even the weak detection is impossible
so with this
result now our task just reduced to
computing
this quantity the second moment of like
ratio
um so to do that i need to introduce the
cycle decomposition permutation so just
let me briefly review that so given a
node permutation sigma
we can it can always induce and
naturally induce an edge permutation
which i call sigma subscript e here on
the n choose two
uh ordered pairs uh as follows
okay so in particular sigma through e
and
apply to i j just equal to the edge
sigma i comma sigma j
now let me give example to illustrate
the cycle decomposition
so let's consider a simple case when n
is a six
and sigma is given by the following
cycle decomposition
where we have one fixed point and then
one two cycle
and then one three cycle so now
based on this you can naturally write
out
the cycle decomposition for the induced
etch permutation
so for example the two cycle in the node
permutation
actually induces a fixed point in the
actual permutation because you can check
that
two comma three mapped to itself under
sigma
right um you can also see that
if you take one two cycle in the node
permutation and one three cycle in the
node permutation
this induces a sixth cycle in the edge
permutation
just by considering all the pairs two
four
and then the corresponding mapping will
become three five and so on so forth
so i want to mention that this cycle
decomposition of experimentation
actually gives a partition of all these
entries two pairs and in these talks i'm
going to call the cycles
like orbits so the cycles in another
permutation will be called node
orbit and cycles in the edge permutation
we are called edge of it
so now with this cycle decomposition
then we can proceed with the second
moment calculation
so the important thing here is that
under the alternate hypothesis
the distribution p is a mixture
distribution
mixing over this underlying latent
permutation
so you plug in this mixture distribution
you take square and this will naturally
induces
two independent copies of permutation pi
tilde and
pi with the product of x i j
and each x i j is nothing but the
likable ratio of the corresponding pair
and now here with the cycle
decomposition then we can regroup
the product according to the edge orbit
the orbits of the edge permutation where
here i would
mention sigma is actually just the
difference between pi and pi tilde
and now with that then we can take
expectation over q
over both hand sides and then
interchange the expectation
so now the important thing is that why
we need the cycle decomposition is
because
the edge orbits are disjoint so xo will
become
independent across different o so that's
why we can pour the expectation
inside the product and it will arrive at
the expectation of xo
where xo remember is just the product of
x i j over all the pairs in these edge
orbits
um it turns out that this expectation of
xo can actually can be explicitly
computed
even though the computation is
complicated
but we get this nice simple expression
so it equals one plus rho to the power
of two times the length of the edge
orbit
where rho is just the correlation
coefficient
so this means that for the longer orbits
it actually contributes less to the
second moment
and this we will actually utilize later
in our proof
i also mentioned that how to get this
expression we use this so-called
igor chef method to kind of use the
control integral representation of the
binomial coefficient
so that's how we get this formula here
and now with that then we can combine
everything and then we can show that the
second moment
of the likelihood ratio is actually
equal to 1 plus little one
when rho squared is smaller than 2 log n
over m but unfortunately when rho
squared is bigger than 2 log n over n
this actually blows up to plus
infinity and then if you compare the
negative condition that we get here
with the condition that we present
earlier
this condition is actually sub-optimal
by a bounded factor
when p is small so somehow we need to
revamp the second moment to show a title
result
so to do that we need to understand like
what causes the second moment blows up
even though the total variation distance
remains small
okay so it turns out that the second
moment blows
up due to this obstruction from these
short orbits
so one easy way to visualize this or to
see this
is to consider the lower bound by
considering
the scenario that these two independent
permutation pi 2 and pi
coincided with each other and this
happens with this very small probability
one over n factorial
but when this happens then the edge
permutation just reduced to
n choose two fixed points so that's why
you have this one plus rho square to the
power of n choose two
and then if you check that this
expression actually blows up to infinity
when rho squared is bigger than two log
n of n and that's
precisely reason why the second moment
blows up
so this calculation you can actually
carry out the similar calculation
even for short orbits beyond fixed point
and you will see that the second moment
still blows up
but at a slightly different threshold
because of short albums
so the crucial observation that we get
from here is that
the second moment blows up because of
this atypically large magnitude
given by this product of xo for short
orbits of length
k up to log n so if we want to make sure
the second moment is bounded
somehow we need to regulate the product
of x0 for those short objects
and these actually give our give rise
our like this so-called conditional
second movement
so in the dance regime this is
relatively simple to do
because it suffices to consider fixed
point
uh in particular it suffice to consider
the edge orbits of lens
1 and this product xo for all this
fixed point roughly equals 1 over p
raised to the power of 2 times this
quantity here
so f here is just a set of fixed point
of this node permutation sigma
and this a intersection b pi is just the
intersection graph that we mentioned
earlier
so this is the graph that includes all
the common edges
in a and b pi and now this e
this quantity here is nothing but the
number of edges
of the subgraph of this intersection
graph induced by the fixed
point in the node permutation so if this
sub graph induced by f is dense then
this will
create a large magnitude of product of
xo
so we need to somehow regulate the
subgraph density
and here i want to mention that the f
depends on pi and pi tilde
so it's so it's impossible to directly
regulate
or control the subgraph density over the
graph induced by f
so that's why we actually instead
consider a uniform
concentration so luckily under the
alternative process p then actually for
every sub graph s
the subgraph density the number of edges
actually concentrates uniformly
as long as the sub graph size is large
so now we can conditional on this
typical event under this p
and then when the cardinality of the
fixed point is launched
then by putting an indicator here this
naturally induces
a control over the maximum possible
value of the number of edges induced by
f
and then you can compute this
calculation and that's how we prove the
result in the dance region
um for the sparse region it turns out
that
the situation is much more complicated
that is because we need to consider
all the edge orbits up to length log n
so we divide our analysis into three
different categories
the first one is the long cycles like
those orbits of length
above log n and turns out that for those
long
orbits they contribute one plus little
one
to the second moment already by just
plugging in the vernina second moment
calculation
now we left with a short orbit so we
further divide into the case where
the orbit as a set of edges is not
totally included in the edge set of the
intersection graph
in this case it turns out that we can
directly bound
the expected value of xo so it's already
upper bounded by one
so the only treble comes from these
short
complete orbits those objects that are
completely included in the edge set of
the intersection graph
because at this case the xo actually
induces the maximum possible value that
is one over p
to the power of two times the length of
o so somehow we need to control
like the number of such short complete
orbits
so that's why here we actually in
like uh imposed a condition mps square
less than one because in this case since
the intersection graph
the average degree is actually bounded
away from one
so this is actually a pseudo forest it's
in the subcritical region
so it's a pseudo forest with high
probability so the pseudo force here
just means that
every component in this graph having at
most one cycle
okay so because of this pseudoforest
constraint this naturally limits
like the number of complete orbits that
can occur in the intersection graph
so in particular we look at this union
of all the edge orbits
short complete edge orbits we call it hk
here
and h k is again a sub graph of
intersection graph
so it is a pseudo forest so we're going
to use this pseudo force constraint
to control the expected value of product
of xo for short
complete orbits so that's
what what we're going to do so
conditional on this high probability
event
that's the intersection graph is a
pseudo forest under
p then we're able to bound the expected
value of product xo
for those short orbits and this turns
out to be
can be upper bounded by just the
generating function
of the pseudo forest that can be
generated from the edge orbits of lands
and mos
okay so in particular now the next
step is to bound this generating
function
so the key challenge left is to
enumerate this orbit
pseudo forest somehow using the opposite
structure
so here it is crucial to use the object
structure because if you don't use
object structure and just treat this as
a general pseudo forest
the resulting bound of the generating
function won't be enough
so the next thing for our illumination
is try to understand
the edge orbit structure so in
particular
we classify the edge orbits based on how
they are generated
uh into the following four types the
first type
we call the matching like denoted by n
this actually is generated by the two
node orbits of same size
for example here we have one node orbit
one two
and no one node orbit three four and
this will
generate an edge orbit one three and two
four
if we view this as a graph this is just
a matching
between the nodes of the node object of
the same size
so that's why we call it matching type
the second type is called bridging this
is actually generated from the node
orbits of different sizes or lenses
so for example here we have one node
orbit of size two
and one node orbit of size four and then
the edge orbits
generated can be viewed as a bipartite
graph between the nodes
in these two node orbits and that's why
we call it the bridging
the last two types actually are just the
edge orbits generated within the same
node orbit so for example the type c
edge orbit is just a cycle within this
node orbit
and then type s edge orbit is just
splitting this
node orbit into two parts so after
identifying these
different types of edge orbits we need
to understand
how these edge orbits can co-occur in
the graph
under the pseudo force constraint so the
first thing is that the type c
edge orbit is already a cycle as you can
see here
so under the pseudo force constraint you
cannot have multiple
type c edge orbits within the same
component
also a very important property for the
bridge is that if you look at this
type b m comma l etch orbit where
l is the length of the shorter node
orbit
and m is the length of the longest node
orbit
so as you can see here l divides by
m so the bridge is actually cycle free
but otherwise if l does not divide m
you will discover that it contains a
component with at least two cycles
so under the pseudo force constraint you
can only have this type bml edge orbit
when l divides m so the key to our
elimination is try to identify all these
possible forbidden co-occurrence
patterns for the edge orbits under the
pseudo-force constraint
so due to the time constraint i won't go
into the details about our illumination
but i just
actually i'm sorry to interrupt just
going to mention that so that we have
time for questions
your time is kind of close to over so
good time to wrap up
yeah yes so i'm not going to the details
about the illumination but i just want
to mention that
we crucially use the edge orbit
structure
to illuminate the possible
edge orbit pseudo forest
um so after getting the so this actually
found
our final bound on the generating
function
and after getting this the last step is
to take the average over the permutation
and this step we actually use the
personal approximation of the number of
um cycles in the node permutation
okay so let me conclude my talk so in
this talk we formulated the problem of
testing network correlation and
characterize the statistical detection
limit
the impossibility proof actually applies
the conditional second moment
method the sparse setting is
particularly challenging we leverage
this pseudo-forest structure of the
subcritical autoshining graphs
and we also see that there exists a
large computational gap
between the statistical computation
elements
so the open problem is to derive sharp
detection threshold in the sparse region
and another open problem is to prove the
existence of or try to close the gap
the computational gaps so for more
details you can check the archive print
and thanks all right thank you very much
xiaoming
yeah we got some great applause um
uh great so uh our next talk is in nine
minutes so we have plenty of time for
questions so uh if there's anything that
you'd like dropping to go over you have
some questions for him
uh let's hear him um i have a question
sorry i have two questions oh
i wait i'll go after jane okay oh you
can go first chris you can go first
oh yeah it's me go ahead jane
oh hi um yeah i just wonder um if the
this
strong detectability property has the
following
convex property so if i'm giving you two
two probabilities p1 p2 they they are
asymptotically the same and you have g
and p
1 and g and p 2. now i'm just giving you
a random very
oh sorry random graph that's you don't
know it's distribution but it's strictly
between
np1 and gnp g and p2
right so it's a subgraph of the larger
one and content
the the other one as a subgraph so
now you know the results for the two
ends can you actually
say something about the detectability
for
for the or the one that's sandwiched by
these two gmp
um i see um yeah so i think like uh
one thing that you can say maybe it's
based on like the property of the total
variation distance
so if you because uh all this
detectability
uh boils down to computing the total
division distance right
so if you can derive the total variation
distance um
and like a like four so so for the setup
that you described then i think you can
get immediately the
um like the condition for for the
detection
so in other words if you look at the
graph sandwich between these two
endpoints
um so if you can derive the torah's
distance then i think you can get the
result that you want
but i don't know exactly what whether
this is possible
to divide the totalization this amount
on top of my head right now
but i think that's something that like
something can check
and also i want to mention that there's
a data processing in quality so if you
can
um like construct a minecraft kernel
then
this also naturally induces alterations
and okay so the second question
is have you ever considered the um the
parent graph
to be sampled from other space like
random regular graph for instance
yeah so actually in this work so we
haven't thought about that
but indeed you can consider other
possible uh
like a graph family for the grand graph
like one
one thing that i don't talk in this do
not mention this talk is that
the gaussian setting so the parent graph
is a complete graph
complete weighted graph with a gaussian
weight
and then you can think about you have
two graphs that are corrupted version
of this parent gaussian widget graph so
that's one possibility
and then for the regular graph actually
i haven't saw it too much
like along that line but i think that
can be also
uh considered under this framework
thank you very much yeah you're welcome
okay chris you want to go ahead and
after that i'll have a question from the
the audience
we're uh drumming i just want to make
sure i understand kind of the
the analytic heart of your calculations
so
i s if i understood correctly
um the likelihood ratio that you get
is uh a generating function of the cycle
structure where a cycle of a given
length has
you know contributes something ex which
exponentially decays in its length and
then maybe there's
also something for the number of cycles
is that correct
um yes i think that's more or less
correct so basically
yeah so you're right so if you look at
the square
of the like ratio this just boils down
to
the expectation of the product of the
bunch of contributions from
orbits of different lenses good and so
yeah the reason i asked so as i'm as i'm
sure you know like
this generating function for uniformly
random permutations
is a kind of classic calculation so what
you've done
here is calculate um
the analogous generating function for
the permutation induced on the edges by
a uniformly random
permutation of the vertices is that
correct
um okay
i think it's related but i but i don't
think it is
exactly that so for example this the so
the generating function actually
indeed comes from in the sparse case uh
basically is that in this case
uh the contribution from this so-called
short complete orbit just reduced to
this one over p to the power of two
times the length of o
so basically to control this we just
need to understand
how many such short complete orbits can
occur in this intersection graph
so i mean it's related to the random
permutation
but it's not directly just a property of
random permutation
so it also relates to this intersection
graph
that i want okay well we
we can take this offline i was just
wondering if there was some beautiful
sort of representation theoretic way to
do this calculation
since we can you know the the
the permutation induced on edges
uh you know there are ways to understand
that representation of
permutations right so maybe i want to
distinguish two things
one is what i call edge permutation so
that is the edge is in terms of computer
graph
so that's why every node permutation
just naturally induce an electrical
mutation
including all the pairs and then the
second thing here is edge
can also occur in the intersection graph
so that is a random graph
so there the edge is really about this
random valve
structure of the other chain graph
structure so i i think what i want to
say is that this generating function is
not just
about the property of this permutation
itself but also
involves uh the random graph
okay great well and of course i was
sorry yeah okay
maybe i should take it back it so like
after down the computation in the end
the degenerating function just boils
down to
after you take the expectation over the
graphs good good okay
because then i was going to ask you
about the hypergraph version where we
would have
the induced permutation on triples
or larger tuples of vertices from
a uniformly random permutation of the
vertices and i'm
i'm that seems like a nice direction to
go
i have two questions from the audience
which i hope we have time for one is
from
anna rude sweetheart maybe more of an
algorithmic question
uh the question is can you your results
on hypothesis testing be extended to
recover anything
about the true vertex correspondence the
permutation in the case that they are
correlated
um not not not directly because here as
i said we focus on this hypothesis
testing version of the graph matching
so the results here do not directly kind
of imply for example some algorithm or
or some result about graph matching like
recovering the latent permutation so
yeah it's just a difference between
hypothesis testing and then the recovery
or estimation
just a quick comment on this sorry like
but what about the impossibility result
is there any case you can get from the
possibility of detection and possibility
of recovery
i see yeah that's a good point so i
think right now
uh we don't know the rigorous um like
the answer for that but i think it is
possible for example
to from the impossibility of of
detection to get some impossibility of
recovery
but uh at this moment i'm not sure so
that's often just
to my understanding it's often case by
case so for this particular particular
problem i haven't
done the calculation uh charming we have
a question also from
nui new who asks could you elaborate on
how the total variation distance
is related to the hypothesis testing
problem the total variation is symmetric
with respect to the two graphs are the
two hypotheses h0 and h1 also symmetric
um okay so i don't fully catch the
question but
in terms of turbination distance and
also the detectability
so i think uh the sum of type 1 and type
2 error in the hypothesis testing
problem is just one minus the total
division distance
so if you can show the total direction
distance for example is 1 plus little 1
this directly implies
the sum of type 1 and type 2 error is
vanishing
on the other hand if you show the
totalized distance it's bound away from
one that just just means that
you need to suffer some constant error
probability for sum of
sum of type 1 type 2 errors so that's
that's the connection that i know
okay thanks uh maybe if jess could set
up
slides and jumping actually there is one
more question from seal i don't know if
you want to squeeze it in
okay we have two more questions oh boy
hmm
well maybe it's best we just continue
with the talks actually sorry about this
but like bryce we have a question from
bryce wong and we also had a question
from
uh salil sram so if the three of you
could
get together at some point and ask your
questions that'd be great
yeah sure okay